Mona Vetsch -
drei Tage auf der Akutstation
in der psychiatrischen Klinik.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Guten Tag, Frau Mona Vetsch!
- Guten Tag!
Freut mich. Mona Vetsch.
- Guten Tag. Mich auch.
Sie sind hier beim Fernsehteam
dabei, oder? Führen Sie ein wenig?
Ich bin einfach drei Tage hier
und schaue,
wie man hier lebt und wer hier lebt.
Genau.
(Und schon sind alle
Berührungsängste beiseite gewischt
und ich bin mittendrin.)
Alles Gute!
(Etwas vom Ersten, das ich lerne
über die Menschen und das Leben
in einer psychiatrischen Klinik:
Viele wollen zwar gern erzählen,
aber nur wenige wollen,
dass man dabei ihr Gesicht sieht.)
(Eine Ausnahme ist der Patient,
bei dem Zamzam jetzt Blut nimmt.)
Ja, komm! Komm!
Darf ich einfach Hallo sagen?
Ich bin Mona Vetsch.
Christian. Freut mich.
- Ich bin Mona. Freut mich.
Ist es für dich in Ordnung,
dass wir jetzt mit Kameras
zu dir ins Zimmer kommen?
Ja, das ist okay.
- Gut. Super.
Ich tue einfach so,
als ob sie nicht hier wären.
Ja, das ist gut.
- Ich fokussiere mich voll auf dich.
Nein, eigentlich
fokussiere ich mich auf dich.
Das ist auch gut. Es ist flott, dass
du vorbeikommst und zu mir schaust.
Brauchst du gerade jemanden,
der etwas zu dir schaut?
Hm ... Ich muss selber
zu mir schauen. Das darf ich lernen.
Ich habe genug Leute,
die zu mir schauen. - Gut.
Aber ich muss
selber zu mir schauen.
Bist du schon lange hier?
- Seit gestern. - Seit gestern?
(Ich bin etwas verwirrt.)
(Wahrscheinlich,
weil ich mir einen Patienten
in der psychiatrischen Klinik
irgendwie anders vorgestellt hätte,
irgendwie
nicht so normal wie Christian.)
Was ist es denn? Was hast du?
Kann man das sagen?
Was ist es, das dich
in die Psychiatrie gebracht hat?
Ich glaube, es hat viel
mit meiner Persönlichkeit zu tun.
Ich bin sehr aktiv. Und auch
mit meiner Einstellung zur Arbeit.
Das ist für mich sehr wichtig.
Ich habe mich
lange darüber definiert
oder definiere mich
immer noch darüber.
Ich habe einfach genug gearbeitet
und habe mich schlecht abgegrenzt.
Also eine Art Burn-out,
kann man das sagen?
Oder hattest du einen Zusammenbruch?
Das gab es auch schon.
Aber es ist eher eine Erschöpfung,
eine Müdigkeit, eine Depression.
(Früher hiess die grosse Klinik
am Rand der Stadt Bern Waldau.)
(Heute sagt man
Universitäre Psychiatrische Dienste
Bern, kurz UPD.)
236 Betten, und es sind
praktisch immer alle besetzt.)
* Schreien *
(Hier auf der Station König
werden max. 20 Patienten behandelt.)
(Auf den ersten Blick
wirkt alles hell und offen,
aber hinaus
kommst du hier nicht so einfach.)
Sind hier eigentlich
alle eingesperrt?
Eben nicht.
Deshalb haben wir diese Chips.
Wir haben so viele verschiedene
Patientinnen und Patienten.
Alle haben andere Bedürfnisse.
Einige brauchen mehr Sicherheit,
einige weniger.
Die, die das weniger brauchen
und selbstständig hinaus sollten,
möchten wir nicht einsperren.
Deshalb haben die diesen Chip.
Deshalb bekommst auch du ihn,
damit du rein und raus kannst.
Okay, das ist mein Schlüssel
in die Freiheit.
Es ist ein etwas komisches Gefühl.
Ist "eingesperrt" das falsche Wort?
Was hast du vorher gesagt?
Dass sie das brauchen.
- Dass sie andere Bedürfnisse haben.
Nach mehr Sicherheit
in dieser Phase.
Es ist also nicht so,
dass ihr sie einsperrt,
sondern ihnen hier Sicherheit gebt,
wenn sie nicht hinaus können.
Das sage ich natürlich
aus pflegerischer Sicht.
Wenn ihr jemanden fragen würdet,
der keinen Ausgang hat,
würde der sicher sagen:
"Ich bin eingesperrt."
Das ist die subjektive Empfindung,
die sie in dem Moment sicher haben.
Zamzam nimmt mich dorthin mit,
wo es gerade am lautesten ist.
Im Aufenthaltsraum trifft man sich
zum Therapieprogramm.
Du darfst dich
als nächstes hier anschliessen.
Aha! Also hier wird selbst gekocht.
Hallo! Michaela.
- Ich bin Mona Vetsch.
Das freut mich sehr.
Du bist die Leiterin der Kochgruppe?
Genau.
Ich bin Milieu- und Gestaltungs-
fachfrau für diese Station.
Wir machen
sehr viele Aktivitäten pro Woche.
Donnerstags
kochen wir auf der Station.
Heute gehen wir hinaus zum Grill.
(Mitmachen ist freiwillig,
aber viele
scheinen froh um die Abwechslung.)
Hallo. Manfred.
- Hallo! Ich bin Mona.
Es war eigentlich eine Reise an den
Nordpol zu den Nordlichtern geplant.
Drei Wochen.
- Bei dir?
Ja, mit meiner Frau.
Aber dann hatte ich einen Hexen-
schuss und eine Magendarminfektion.
Aber unter diesen Umständen
traute ich mich nicht.
Was mache ich am Nordpol,
wenn es mir schlecht geht?
Macht keinen Sinn.
- Dann haben wir das abgeblasen.
Und jetzt bist du hier.
- Jetzt bin ich hier.
Arbeitest du hier
oder wohnst du hier?
Ich bin Patient.
- Du bist Patient, okay.
Ich sehe den Leuten nicht an,
wer hier arbeitet
und wer Patient ist.
Ja, ja.
Ich bin ein arbeitender Patient.
Ein arbeitender Patient,
der nicht an den Nordpol geht.
(Es stellt sich heraus:
Manfred mit dem schönen Wiener
Dialekt ist pensionierter Koch.)
(Und er ist jetzt zum dritten Mal
hier in der psychiatrischen Klinik.)
Hier habe ich wirklich meine Ruhe.
Ich male,
ich mache sämtliche Therapien mit.
Und, ja ...
Hier kann ich wieder Kraft sammeln.
Abgesehen von den Medikamenten.
Ich habe Valium bekommen,
als ich eingetreten bin.
Valium? Boah,
das ist aber ziemlich harter Stoff.
Damit ich mich beruhige.
Aber - die Ärztin weiss es noch
gar nicht - ich habe es abgesetzt.
Ich sage ihr, dass ich
das Zeug nicht mehr brauche.
Aber ist es schlau,
das einfach selber abzusetzen?
Ich schaffe das schon. Doch, doch.
Aber ich sage es ja.
Ich bin ja so ehrlich.
Und wenn sie sagt,
ich soll es lieber noch nehmen ...
Aber das Valium macht mich müde
und ich komme mir manchmal vor
wie unter Drogen oder wie besoffen.
Diesen Zustand mag ich gar nicht.
Du hast gesagt,
du drehst manchmal etwas durch.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen?
Panikattacken.
- Ah, ja.
Schlottern, Panikattacken.
Lustlos, depressiv.
Manchmal denke ich mir: Wenn ich
jetzt ins Bett gehe und einschlafe,
hätte ich nichts dagegen,
am Morgen nicht mehr aufzuwachen.
Aber ich habe selber
keine Selbstmordgedanken, das nicht.
Andererseits denke ich wieder:
Das Leben ist doch schön,
warum bist du so blöd,
warum tust du so blöd?
Aber wenn es nicht geht,
geht es nicht.
Sonst wäre ich ja nicht hier.
(Heute Mittag öffnet sich
die Stationstür auch für die,
die nicht
wie ich einen Badge haben.)
(Draussen im Garten
macht Christian den Grillmeister.)
(Etwas tun zu können,
nützlich zu sein, ist wichtig.)
(Nicht nur für ihn,
der im Job immer 120 % gegeben hat.)
* Nachdenkliche Glockenklänge *
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie nehmen das vielleicht nicht?
Ja.
- Soll ich es wieder mitnehmen?
Brauchen Sie es nicht?
- Nein.
Gut. Vielen Dank.
(Für viele von uns
und auch für mich,
ist es eine beängstigende Vorstel-
lung, mal in die Psychi zu kommen.)
(Aber wie sehen das
die Menschen hier am Tisch,
die Erfahrung haben
statt Vorurteile?)
(Z.B. Caroline: Nach einem Klinik-
aufenthalt lebt sie wieder zu Hause
und kommt nur noch tageweise.
Früher arbeitete sie als Managerin.
Dann habe ich gemerkt:
Am schwierigsten zu managen
bin ich selbst.
Tausende Leute zu managen
ist ganz einfach.
Für mich selbst
braucht es viel mehr Kraft und Mut.
Ab und zu komme ich auch
als Patientin hierher.
Ich bin immer froh,
wenn ich eingesperrt bin,
damit ich mir nichts antue.
- Ah, wirklich?
Ich bin in Sicherheit
und es sind andere da,
die mich vor mir selbst
schützen können.
Ich bin mein schlimmster Feind.
Hier finde ich
Freundschaft mit mir selbst
und auch mit anderen Leuten.
Ich finde,
man geht in die Psychiatrie,
um sich helfen zu lassen.
Das ist ein Schritt, den man macht.
Wenn man dort ist, kann man
die Hilfe annehmen oder eben nicht.
Das ist die grosse Kunst.
- Die Hilfe annehmen zu können.
Nicht unbedingt Hilfe zu suchen,
sondern wenn man hier ist ...
... sie annehmen zu können.
- Warum ist das schwierig?
Scham.
Scham ist vorhanden.
Man weiss nicht,
wie man mit dem Problem umgeht.
Wenn du zum Psychiater gehst,
ist das noch cool. Jemand tut etwas.
Aber wenn du stationär
in einer Psychiatrie bist,
kommt sofort so ein "Oh!".
* Schluchzen *
Wie ein erstes Einatmen.
Je ne suis pas dans la psychiatrie.
* Schluchzen *
Pas la psychiatrie.
Sch, sch!
Oi, oi, oi.
* Schluchzen *
Es ist nicht einfach.
- Nein.
Du hast gesagt,
man muss es auch lernen.
Aber offenbar ist es auch
für die Leute, die hier sind,
nicht einfach, mit der Situation
umzugehen, in der Psychi zu sein.
Ja, das ist so.
Und v.a. auch für die Angehörigen.
Auch sie haben Mühe,
darüber zu reden.
Denn sie haben keine Depression.
Das dachte ich vor 20 Jahren auch:
Was ist eine Depression?
Da ist man einfach schlecht drauf.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Und wenn man es dann mal hat,
hätte man lieber
einen achtfachen Beinbruch,
den man sieht und der schmerzt.
Warum?
Eine Depression
ist ein Schmerz im Innern,
den man irgendwie nicht fassen kann.
Man muss einfach Geduld haben,
bis es besser wird.
* Nachdenkliche Glockenklänge *
Wir können feststellen,
wie sich beim Einatmen
unter den Händen
der Brustkorb leicht anhebt.
(Am Nachmittag begleite ich
den Tagespatienten Thomas
und Manfred ins Yoga.)
(Alle halten einen langen Ton aus.)
(Das Ziel: das ständige Drehen
im Kopf herunterfahren
und lernen, zur Ruhe zu kommen.)
Das habe ich mir jetzt verdient.
Nach dem Yoga, jawohl.
Es ist aber gut.
Dann gibt es noch etwas,
das heisst Tiefenentspannung.
Da muss man sich
überhaupt nicht bewegen.
Man liegt nur und sie erzählt
eine Geschichte oder es läuft Musik.
Und atmen, in alle Richtungen,
alle Gegenden, jeden Körperteil.
Das ist wahnsinnig entspannend.
(Zurück auf der Station König
ist noch viel vom Tag übrig.)
(Zeit, um sich abzulenken
oder um nachzudenken.)
* Friedliche Melodie *
(Die friedliche Stimmung trügt.)
(Hier drin
kämpft jeder seinen eigenen Kampf
gegen seelische Abgründe,
gegen Ängste und Dämonen.)
(In der Schweiz wird jeder Zweite
einmal im Leben psychisch krank.)
(Dennoch haben wir immer das Gefühl,
das gehe nur die anderen etwas an.)
* Langer Schrei im Hintergrund *
(Nach einem Tag auf der Akutstation
ist mir klar:
Hier drin sind alles
Menschen wie du und ich.)
* Nachdenkliche Glockenklänge *
(Morgens um 8 Uhr in der
psychiatrischen Uniklinik von Bern.)
(Im Auftrag von Zamzam
mörsere ich Medikamente
für eine frisch eingelieferte
Patientin,
die künstlich ernährt wird.)
(Zamzam) So!
Ah! Wie kann man die brechen?
Ich kann sie in warmes Wasser ...
- Ah, schau jetzt!
Ich habe Angst,
dass sie rausspringt.
* Hohes Piepen *
(Und dann der Alarm.
Diese Patientin braucht Hilfe.)
* Klopfen *
(Zamzam) Ich komme sofort!
Ich muss mich kurz anziehen.
(Es ist ein schwieriger Fall.)
(Dieser Patientin geht es nach einer
schweren Operation im Inselspital
auch psychisch schlecht.
Deshalb wurde sie hierher verlegt.)
(Wegen der Infektionsgefahr
muss sich Zamzam
für jeden Besuch in ihrem Zimmer
umziehen.) - Hallo!
Er kommt. Er hat nicht gesagt,
zu welcher Uhrzeit.
Kann ich dir helfen?
Brauchst du etwas?
Weisst du, was mega nett wäre?
Zwei Tassen. Weisst du, wo sie sind?
- Ja, weiss ich.
Und etwas lauwarmes Wasser
und die Medikamente,
die wir gemörsert
und aufgelöst haben.
Super!
(Es ist ein hektischer Morgen
auf der Station.)
Guten Morgen.
Super, vielen Dank.
- Bitte.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass ich mich
nicht aus- und wieder anziehen muss.
Wozu trägst du das?
Zum Schutz für sie.
Also, ich bin gleich zurück.
Ich gehe
die Medikamente verabreichen.
(So etwas wie Alltag
oder sogar Routine
gibt es bei dieser Arbeit kaum,
habe ich den Eindruck.)
(Jeder Mensch und jedes
seelische Leiden ist wieder anders.)
(Wer hier
wie Zamzam in der Pflege arbeitet,
wird immer wieder
aufs Neue herausgefordert.)
So.
- Das ist ja ein komplizierter Fall.
Ja, genau.
Was sind im Alltag für dich die
schwierigen, anstrengenden Fälle?
Die anstrengenden?
Das sind die ...
Wie soll ich das jetzt erklären?
Die, die nicht verstehen,
was wir mit ihnen machen.
Das finde ich schwierig.
Die, die einen Zwang erleben,
weil sie nicht verstehen, warum,
und die die Einsicht nicht haben.
Später schon. Man kann es
nachbesprechen und alles ist gut.
Aber in diesem Moment
ist es für uns alle schwierig.
Z.B. etwas durchzusetzen,
das der andere nicht will.
Hattest du eine gute Nacht?
- Es geht. Aber sie ist ja vorbei.
Also muss man sie
nicht mehr beurteilen.
Ah.
- Es geht mir jetzt gut.
Gut, das ist super.
Das ist tipptopp.
Du hast mir gestern
noch eine Frage gestellt.
Ging dir eine von gestern nach?
Ich habe sie noch nicht beantwortet.
- Aha.
Du hast mich gefragt, was der Unter-
schied zwischen hier und daheim ist.
Ja. Und, was ist er?
Ich glaube,
der grösste Unterschied ist ...
Hier bin ich zurückgezogen, in Ruhe,
abgekapselt und studiere weniger.
Du studierst hier weniger?
- Weniger.
Ich hätte gedacht,
man studiert hier mehr,
denn zu Hause und wenn man arbeitet,
lenkt einen alles so gut ab.
Wenn man arbeitet.
Aha.
Wenn du jetzt also nicht hier wärst,
wenn du zu Hause wärst,
draussen wärst,
wie ginge es dir dann?
Was wäre dann mit dir?
Mir ginge es ...
Mir ginge es auch gut.
Was dort einfach ist, ist:
Man hat so Phasen im Tag,
oder ich habe Phasen im Tag,
in denen ich nicht mag
und in denen ich nichts mag.
Ja.
- Und die sind meistens am Morgen.
Das wird irgendwann für mich und
auch für meine Frau zur Belastung.
Ich glaube, mit all den psychischen
Erkrankungen, die man heute kennt -
und jeder kennt jemanden,
der schon ein Burn-out hatte -
ist auch die Angst da,
dass man sich damit aus dem Rennen
nimmt und keine Chance mehr bekommt.
Ja, von der Gesellschaft.
Wer stellt jemanden ein,
der krank war,
bei dem die Chance besteht,
dass er wieder psychisch krank wird?
Hättest du es früher gemacht?
Jemanden eingestellt?
- Ja, mit dieser Geschichte.
Das kann ich dir
so nicht beantworten.
Danke.
Was macht es mit dir?
- Ja, genau!
Ich glaube, das ist ...
Sich z.B.
eine Depression vorzustellen,
wenn man keine Depression hat,
ist wahnsinnig schwierig.
Ich versuche mir dich
als kranken Menschen vorzustellen.
Wenn du so neben mir sitzt
und mit mir sprichst ...
... hast du nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich krank bin, gell?
Nein. - Gell?
- Das ist eben das Problem.
Genau, das ist auch mein Problem.
Das ist auch dein Problem,
dass du gar nicht krank wirkst.
Oder was?
- Nein.
Ich habe einfach gelernt,
immer alles zu überspielen.
Ich habe gelernt,
im Leben tapfer zu sein
und keine Schwäche zu zeigen.
Ich habe einfach gelernt,
das in mich hineinzufressen
und mich zurückzuziehen
und mir selbst zu sagen:
"Ach, das ist nicht so schlimm."
"Das wird schon wieder."
"Du musst doch jetzt nicht!"
"Lass es jetzt einfach!"
(Was Christian erzählt,
kennen viele.)
* Schrei im Hintergrund *
(Die Angst, nicht mehr mitzukommen,
die Arbeit zu verlieren
und nicht mehr dazuzugehören.)
(Vielleicht sagt man deshalb,
dass psychiatrische Kliniken
immer auch ein Spiegel
unserer Gesellschaft sind.)
* Nachdenkliche Glockenklänge *
Ich komme.
Ich habe solche Angst.
Ja, Sie haben Angst. Das weiss ich.
Wo sitzt denn diese Angst?
- Ich weiss auch nicht. Hier oben.
Dort oben sitzt sie?
- Ja.
Und was macht diese Angst mit Ihnen?
- Sie macht mich fast fertig.
Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
sie erdrückt mich.
* Wimmern *
Drückt sie Ihnen fast die Luft ab?
- Ja.
Ich habe solche Angst.
* Schluchzen *
Was muss ich machen?
Sch, sch! Ganz ruhig atmen,
ganz ruhig atmen!
Jetzt atmen wir ein.
Jetzt atmen wir aus.
Wir atmen ein.
Wir atmen aus.
Und ein.
Und aus.
* Unartikuliertes Rufen *
Sch, sch!
So, dann gehen wir weiter.
* Klopfen *
(Am späten Vormittag ist Arztvisite.
Bei Manfred dürfen wir dabei sein.)
Herr Hartmann, guten Morgen.
Kommen Sie doch zu Ihrem Bett,
dann haben Sie ein Heimspiel.
Guten Morgen.
Mir geht es sehr viel besser
seit Freitag, seit dem Eintritt.
Aber ich bin noch relativ müde,
aber das kann ...
Aber nicht mehr so schlimm.
Und ich nehme diese Tabletten
nicht mehr.
Die darf ich zurückgeben.
- Was ist es?
Ich glaube, Valium.
- Das ist Motilium.
Ah! Okay.
- Ja.
Vielleicht können Sie mir
noch über den Verlauf berichten.
Wir sind zuerst wie letztes Mal
mit einer fixen Dosis Valium
reingegangen,
damit wir die Symptome, die Sie
subjektiv nicht wirklich bemerken,
die man aber von aussen sieht,
dieses Schlottern, Zittern,
wieder unterdrücken können.
Das konnten wir wie beim letzten Mal
sehr schnell,
innert vier Tagen, reduzieren.
Jetzt sind wir dort auf null.
Ist die Visite fertig?
- Ja.
Darf ich Sie kurz abfangen?
Die anderen sind frei,
aber an Sie hätte ich einige Fragen.
Ja, gern.
Sie haben gerade über Medikamente
gesprochen, auch über die Menge.
Das ist ja eines der Klischees,
die man draussen hat:
Eigentlich
kommt man nur in die Psychiatrie,
um mit Medikamenten
abgefüllt zu werden
und das ist Ihre Lösung. Ist das so?
Es gibt ganz klar
psychiatrische Erkrankungen,
bei denen Medikamente
sehr hilfreich sind
und manchmal auch wirklich nötig.
Dort geht es gar nicht ohne.
Aber das Ziel ist,
das richtige Medikament
in der Dosierung zu verabreichen,
dass es den Patientinnen
und Patienten möglichst gut geht,
mit möglichst wenig Nebenwirkungen.
Es geht also nicht darum,
die Leute zu sedieren
oder schlafen zu legen,
sondern darum,
ein Medikament zu finden,
das gegen die Erkrankung hilft.
(Gegenüber früher hat sich vieles
zum Besseren verändert.)
(Aber warum machen uns psychische
Krankheiten eigentlich so Angst?)
Die psychische Erkrankung
ist wirklich speziell.
betrifft die Seele,
das sind unsere Überzeugungen,
es ist unser Sein, unser Ich.
Unser Innerstes.
- Ja.
Wenn das betroffen ist,
wird es irgendwie unberechenbar,
unklar, auch für die anderen.
Die psychische Erkrankung an sich
ist von einer Aura umgeben
von Zweifeln, von Misstrauen,
"Was ist da los?"
Von Entfremdung, wenn es
jemanden betrifft, den man gern hat.
Ja, ein guter Ausdruck. Man findet
den Kontakt nicht mehr richtig.
Deshalb halten viele Menschen
auch Abstand davon.
Es ist in dieser Situation
die Angst da,
dass ein Mensch nicht mehr so ist,
wie man ihn kennt.
(Die Familie und die Freunde
leiden bei einer
psychischen Krankheit immer mit.)
(Hinzu kommt die Angst
vor der Reaktion der Leute.)
(Sie ist auch heute noch so gross,
dass von den Angehörigen hier
niemand etwas
vor der Kamera sagen möchte.)
(Im Stationszimmer
ist Schichtwechsel.)
(Die Nachtschwester muss wissen,
was tagsüber gelaufen ist.)
(Nachher ist sie die ganze Nacht
allein auf der Station.)
Also, gute Nacht!
- Also, gute Nacht!
(In der Psychiatrie ist es auch
in der Nacht nie ganz still.)
(Eine ältere Frau tigert rastlos
den Gang hoch und runter.)
(Und auch Manfred raucht draussen
noch eine, um zur Ruhe zu kommen.)
Wie empfindest du das? Kannst du
an diesem Ort gesund werden?
Ja, und zwar, weil ich finde,
dass die Leute -
mit welchen Störungen
oder Problemen auch immer -
alle ehrlich sind.
- Ja.
Die verstecken nichts mehr,
die lassen los.
Und solche Leute ...
... sehe ich draussen
im Alltag eben nicht.
Da hat jeder seine Maske auf
und jeder sagt "Mir geht's gut".
Wenn ich sehe,
dass es jemandem schlecht geht,
geht es ihm immer noch gut,
denn das geht schon vorbei.
Jeder belügt sich
und spielt was vor,
obwohl ich merke, dass der leidet.
Aber er gibt es nicht zu.
- Ja.
Wenn du hier rauskommst -
du sagst, du veränderst dich -,
wer bist du dann
oder wie bist du dann?
Ich möchte endlich 100%ig
ich, ich sein.
Du, du?
- Ja, ich, ich sein.
Sodass ich 100%ig
zu mir stehen kann.
Ja. Bist du denn gut darin,
dich selbst zu mögen?
(Zögerlich) Ja.
Ich mochte eigentlich immer
lieber die anderen.
Als dich selbst?
- Ich war gern für die anderen da.
Sei es für die erste Frau,
sei es für die zweite Frau,
sei es für die Tochter,
die ich grossgezogen habe.
Aber ich für mich selbst, ganz
persönlich, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
bin ich ein wenig
auf der Strecke geblieben.
Ich für mich selbst.
- Ja.
Ja, und das ist kein einfacher Weg,
würde ich jetzt sagen.
Ja. Wohin führt er,
was ist dein Gefühl?
Wohin führt dein Weg?
Ich heirate mich selbst.
Nein, aber so ungefähr ...
(So heiter kann es sein
in der psychiatrischen Klinik.)
(Aber auch himmeltraurig.)
(Vieles können wir nicht zeigen.)
(Menschen,
die die ganze Zeit um Hilfe rufen,
die, die nicht mehr wissen,
wo sie sind und wer sie sind.)
(Und daneben die Angehörigen -
überfordert und hilflos.)
(Auch solche Momente
nehme ich mit von hier.)
* Schrei im Hintergrund *
Darf ich einfach hineinkommen?
Guten Morgen, Christian.
Hallo, Mona.
- Du gehst ja, gell? Du bist ...
... am Zusammenpacken, ja.
Jetzt gehst du am Wochenende raus?
- Ja.
Kannst du selber sagen,
wann du raus möchtest?
Ja,  i c h  kann es selber sagen.
Ich bin ja nicht suizidgefährdet
oder sonst etwas,
also darf ich raus.
Diesen Moment gab es bei dir nicht,
dass du das Gefühl hattest ...
Doch! Den gab es
sehr intensiv und sehr lange.
Ah, wirklich?
- Zuerst relativ passiv.
Ich dachte abends einfach:
Es macht nichts,
wenn ich morgen nicht mehr aufwache.
Das war passiv.
Aber dann wurde es teils auch aktiv.
Wenn ich am Bahnhof stand
und der Zug eingefahren ist,
stellte ich mir vor,
etwas weiter vorne zu stehen
und einen Schritt nach vorne
zu machen.
Oder ich hatte auch schon Szenarien,
als ich auf dem Motorrad sass,
dass ich die Augen geschlossen
und die Arme ausgebreitet habe.
Einfach,
um mal zu schauen, was kommt.
Doch, also diese Momente hatte ich.
Krass, wenn du mir das so erzählst.
- Ja, das hatte ich.
Mittlerweile
ist das kein Thema mehr.
(Auch nach drei Tagen
lösen die vielen Medikamente
bei mir
immer noch gemischte Gefühle aus.)
(Abhängigkeit ist ein grosses Thema
in der Psychiatrie.)
Wir machen es so,
dass es immer zwei anschauen.
Die Kollegin ist jetzt nicht hier.
- Ob es drei sind? Das sind drei.
Ob es drei sind, genau.
Eine gewisse Abhängigkeit,
dass Leute ohne diese Medikamente
nicht schlafen oder nicht leben
können, nimmt man in Kauf?
Richtig.
Und was wäre die andere Option?
Wenn man die ganze Zeit
nicht schlafen kann.
Dann würde ich auch lieber
Schlafmedikamente nehmen,
dafür kann ich
einen normalen Alltag führen.
Es gibt ja einige,
die fast Panik haben und die sagen,
ohne Medikamente
seien sie die ganze Zeit nur so.
Mit Medikamenten
könnten sie einigermassen
kommunizieren und funktionieren.
Richtig.
Ja, was ist die andere Option?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
(Aber auch hier
in der psychiatrischen Klinik
vertraut man nicht allein
auf Medikamente,
um seelische Krisen zu meistern.)
(Jeder Patient
muss bei sich selbst anfangen:
In Gesprächstherapien, im Malatelier
oder wie Manfred beim Schreiben,
kann man aufarbeiten,
was falsch gelaufen ist,
und was anders werden soll
im Leben draussen.)
(Zamzam und ihre Kolleginnen
und Kollegen auf der Station König
begleiten die Menschen
auf dem Weg durch die Lebenskrisen.)
Es gibt viele Patientinnen
und Patienten, die ich wirklich mag.
Weil wir lange
zusammen gearbeitet haben
oder weil man sie
einfach als Person mag,
auch wenn man nicht lange
mit ihnen gearbeitet hat.
Dann ist es auch umso schöner,
wenn sie wieder austreten
und es ihnen gut geht.
Wenn sie nicht wieder kommen.
Auch wenn sie wiederkommen.
Dann wissen wir, dass es geht,
dass sie wieder austreten können.
Es gibt Krisen und dann weiss man,
sie können sie bewältigen
und wir helfen ihnen.
Dann treten sie wieder aus.
(Manfred begleitet mich
beim Austritt.)
(Er geht nur kurz nach Hause waschen
und kommt am Abend wieder.)
(Aber meine Zeit hier ist vorbei.)
(Ich hoffe,
dass Manfred und alle anderen hier
bald den gleichen Weg
einschlagen können.)
(Schritt für Schritt zurück
in ein Leben draussen,
in dem sie so angenommen werden,
wie sie sind.)